Hollywood blockbusters have become
increasingly reliant on visual effects
over the past few decades and recent
advances in technology have made it so
feats in VFX work that were considered
impossible just a few years ago are now
well within reach more and more studios
are using CGI and films mostly because
it's often cheaper than the alternative
in fact many modern blockbusters are
covered in so many digital layers that
the original footage looks
unrecognizable and more often than not
completely ridiculous here's what these
movies really look like before special
effects were added 300 rise of an empire
zack snyder's 300 made heavy use of CGI
and the technology used to create it had
advanced immensely by the time its
sequel rise of an empire came around
which of course meant squeezing every
ounce of that tech into the movie
director Noam Murro told Forbes it's
amazing how the tools available eight
years later continued to develop a major
difference is CGI and the ability to
create things in posts that are
convincing and complex and
three-dimensional the idea of creating a
water movie without a drop of water on
the set is remarkable the filmmaker also
revealed that they relied on some of the
same techniques used in the
oscar-winning CGI blockbuster gravity
Elysium Neill Blomkamp's follow-up to
his acclaimed debut district 9 didn't
exactly go as planned despite the star
power of Matt Damon the blockbuster
sci-fi film cost a whopping 115 million
dollars to make but only return 93
million dollars at the domestic box
office but while Blomkamp took full
responsibility for the film's failings
the South African director didn't have
any complaints about the special effects
team which had to put together over
three times as many VFX shots as they
had for district 9 Jurassic world
when Steven Spielberg decided to adapt
Michael Crichton's novel Jurassic Park
CGI as we know it today didn't really
exist
Spielberg brought on Industrial Light
and Magic and tasked them with creating
living breathing dinosaurs using
computer-generated graphics and their
efforts proved revolutionary of course
it wasn't just CGI that brought the
inhabitants of Jurassic Park to life
there were a number of practical effects
used to and ILM mixed it up in the same
way for Jurassic world the fourth film
in the franchise used detailed white
cast
dinosaur heads that would later be
layered with CGI for close-up shots and
they used actors and motion capture
suits to make sure their movement seemed
real VFX supervisor Tim Alexander told
below the line it gave us a new natural
look for the animation we ended up
casting a person to give us a
consistency in the performance there
were individual people being that Raptor
we had suits that they would put on with
the tail Mad Max fury road when George
Miller returned to the world of Mad Max
with his critically acclaimed fury road
in 2015 audiences were blown away by the
sequels frenetic pace and visceral
action much of which was achieved
through the hard work of invented
mechanics who built the vehicles used in
the movie from scratch the chase scenes
were all shot for real but the final
product wouldn't have looked anywhere
near as eye-popping if it weren't for
the VFX team led by supervisor Andrew
Jackson hundreds of CGI artists enhanced
over 2000 shots in fury road from adding
characters to creating an epic toxic
storm the Avengers when Earth's
Mightiest Heroes teamed up on the big
screen in 2012 the stakes were high for
Marvel Studios and their team of visual
effects artists jeff white the film's
VFX supervisor told MTV with Avengers
there were so many things to get right
we created a lot of new york city for
the film and needed to build flying
shots of Iron Man all from photography
we had to build a new Iron Man suit the
mark 7 and stark tower we had to build
the alien race when you add all of those
things up there were quite a few
challenges there green screens were used
during most of the film's action
sequences so the cast spend a good chunk
of time reacting to invisible threats
and taking cover from fake explosions
the biggest hurdle they faced was
inserting the Hulk into group situations
White explained we wanted it to feel
very natural when he's sitting in that
circle of Avengers we spent a lot of
time working on the skin and its hair
and his teeth just to make sure all of
that was believable Man of Steel to
create the illusion of flight Richard
Donner's Superman employed wire rigs to
hang leading man Christopher Reeve in
front of different projected backgrounds
the film is a classic and the effects
look great in the 70s but watching it's
day it feels as though you're flying
with Superman as opposed to him flying
something Man of Steel director Zack
Snyder wanted to avoid when he set out
to make Superman soar Snyder decided to
use a handheld approach to filming
Clark's flying scenes which meant adding
in most of the effects in post wire rigs
and gimbals were used to suspend Henry
Cavill in front of green screens and the
CGI team did the rest
Iron Man 3 when the first Iron Man movie
dropped in 2008 director Jon Favreau
wasn't known for CGI heavy features but
advances in technology had convinced him
to change his stance
I've always steered away from using
visual effects whenever possible
that being said in the last few years
they've been a lot of wonderful visual
effects movies where it's beginning to
become seamless even to me
Favreau returned for the sequel but
Shane black took the reins for Iron Man
3 which contains some of the most
challenging visual effects yet Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige
explained we wanted the ability to be
able to suit up anywhere anyhow without
a giant gantry the answer was having
Tony Stark design outlets he injects
just below the skin not unlike the
comics allowing him to call the Iron Man
suit from anywhere to pull off the
effect each individual piece had to be
digitally added to Robert Downey jr. 's
body after the fact
spider-man homecoming years of
gymnastics training really paid off for
Tom Holland on the set of spider-man
homecoming the characters eagerly
anticipated introduction to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe even with the
advances in CGI in recent years it helps
to have an actor who feels comfortable
jumping around in tights and doesn't
mind hanging around on wires all day
long this was the case with the film's
Washington Monument scene but while that
was indeed Holland under the Spidey mask
the monument itself was a fake erected
on a studio soundstage we couldn't film
at the real Washington Monument but we
built very impressive very large chunks
of the monument for filming Holland got
up the structure with the aid of a wire
rig though even with his background it
was far from a walk in the park
we did two weeks and every single shot
was upside down and my head just took a
pounding man from all the Bloods that
was rushing to it the jungle book the
CGI Jon Favreau used for Iron Man was
nothing compared to what he did for his
20
sixteen live-action adaptation of The
Jungle Book to create an entire jungle
around a human actor they needed to pull
out all the stops
the lighting was particularly difficult
the director explained it's very hard to
fake light and shadow
so everything became about using panels
of LEDs to project life so if we had the
kid bowing before the elephants you have
panels where we actually would pre
animate the elephants and they would
cast the shadows on the kid in the exact
right way
this meant that 12 year old star Neel
Sethi had to imagine the animals he was
interacting with though Favreau was on
hand to make the experience as real as
possible for the young actor via puppets
and actors and blue suits Robocop Paul
Verhoeven's Robocop got the most out of
the special effects available in the 80s
using a combination of stop-motion and
prosthetic builds to create a movie that
was disturbingly realistic at times in a
2014 reboot Murphy gets his injuries in
an explosion that was created digitally
but the suit he thuds afterward was
actually real and there was a philosophy
from the start that we're gonna have a
head-to-toe suit the challenge was
building a suit that was mobile and easy
for the digital department to add on to
the Martian Ridley Scott is no stranger
to special effects but creating the Red
Planet on screen for the Martian may
have been his biggest challenge as a
director while some practical effects
were used a huge amount of digital work
was required to give the Martians
Scott's desired look VFX supervisor
Anders Langlands told Gizmodo Ridley
Scott is famous for doing his little
sketches which are sort of really cool
Ridley Graham's we'd asked what do you
want the background mountains to look
like in this shot and he'd sketch out a
little diagram with what they wanted so
you just literally match that and he'd
be happy a lot of time was spent finding
the right hue for the skies and arid
landscapes of Mars though in the end it
was a simple thing that caused that VFX
team the most problems the helmet visors
but of course gloss spices would reflect
the crew and the lights and the
soundstage so all the helmet visors you
see in the film are actually added in
digitally Suicide Squad David Ayer is
anti-hero ensemble Suicide Squad
definitely had its flaws but few of
those were the fault of the many visual
effects
houses 18 companies in total that work
tirelessly on it image works were the
ones who handled the squad's final
battle with enchantress and the movies
villain proved to be a huge challenge
according to VFX supervisor mark breaks
beer he told our two VFX enchantress was
a unique challenge as the actress had
been shot without a costume as we had
added in later to allow it to behave in
a way that normal cloth or materials
couldn't break spear later told awm that
of the 300 shots they enhanced for the
film's third act dealing with the
Enchantress's tattoos proved the most
difficult that was amazingly tricky to
make sure it looked like skin but also
had the translucency that we needed to
see the subsurface tattoos the wolf of
Wall Street
watching Martin Scorsese's ode to excess
the wolf of Wall Street
the only scenes that stick out as being
possibly computer-generated are the
wondering which Jordan Belfort shot
sinks and the one when a lion wanders
freely through his office but a visual
effects reel released by brain storm
digital revealed that some of the most
basic shots of the movie were rendered
with CGI from sun loungers two tennis
courts brainstorm made plenty of subtle
touches to bring the film in line with
the director's vision VFX producer Marc
Russell told digital arts working with
Martin Scorsese everything is about
propelling a story forward and
contributing to the film I feel that
with his movies there is a kind of
stylized realism to them that we have to
integrate with San Andreas the amount of
destruction on show when this Dwayne
Johnson led blockbuster definitely
doesn't come cheap
but San Andreas actually cost a lot less
to make than many of the big natural
disaster flicks that came before it
according to Variety the production
budget was only one hundred and fourteen
million dollars roughly half the amount
needed to bring Roland Emmerich's 2012
to the big screen the film's visual
effects supervisor Colin Strauss was
able to keep costs down by employing
practical solutions to problems that
most visual effects companies would
solve with only computers today as he
explained it you can make a 100 million
dollar movie look like a 200 million
dollar movie you can make movies way
smarter CG for the sake of CG is always
a mistake they still had their work cut
out for them though 7 different
companies work together to render three
1800 VFX shots for the movie thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]